so as we continue our discussions on
all-new all-different marvel what I want
to do here is pick up with a spider
Gwynn and x-23 team up now to provide a
little bit of context here for those of
y'all who are new to Marvel Comics
spider-gwen was really an accidental
success to be on a spider Gwynn was
designed to be a limited series and it
sold us or it showed us an alternate
reality where Gwen Stacy was bitten by a
radioactive spider
instead of Peter Parker the problem with
this rock it's not really a problem but
the a byproduct of this was that not
only was the suit of spider Gwyn so
attractive to readers but the idea of
Gwen Stacy having spider powers was
attractive as well and so literally
model caught lightning in a bottle and
spider-gwen just took off in popularity
it was insane when she first appeared
you'd go to conventions and you would
see spider-gwen outfits everywhere which
is understandable because a spider-gwen
costume is amazing but with this annual
this serves one of two purposes that
annuals usually serve when I mean here
is that annuals are designed for one of
two things the first is to either
jumpstart a new story
introduce new characters or something
like that we saw Chris Claremont do that
when he first introduced rogue I think
it was Avengers annual number 10 or
maybe was expa annual number 10 was one
of those two but he introduced rode for
the very first time and used that as a
way to basically segue her character
into the Marvel Universe the second is
to simply just fill things for example
right now we are in between the events
of x-23 with regards to Civil War 2 and
the start of a new story arc called
enemy of the state the problem with this
is that there's a little bit of leeway
there enemy of the state is designed to
be part of Marvel now but by the time to
this annual come out Marvel now hadn't
really started yet and so Marvel was
forced with two choices either they
would have to just not have any x-23
titles for you know two or three months
or they could give us annuals that are
designed to literally just tell us the
story and fill some holes and that's
what annuals usually do they just kind
of fill holes or they introduce new
characters and so this team-up is
actually really cool it's actually
really interesting the way it's done but
it also harkens back to a lot of the
older stuff and Marvel Comics with
regards to the original Wolverine James
Howlett
now what happens here is we initially
pick up with x-23 simply not being
herself as it's really kind of strange
here and of course she leaps out a
window
and lands on a car now again keep in
mind that gabby is still with x-23 at
this point of course she's taken Gabby
under her wing for the purpose of
training Gabby on how to be a superhero
teaching her how to how to learn how to
use her abilities how to be effective
but x-23 does not know the fact that
gabby is a very dark person the gabby is
not a very good person
she doesn't know all of that stuff so
for her gabby is just a young girl that
she's taken under her charge who was
designed to be a clone of x-23 and so
when of course Gabby gets downstairs and
she begins to analyze x-23 she was going
on Laura just pops up and starts talking
about how her bones are mending and so
on and so forth but all of this seems
very new to her and what she says is
that she's not Laura Kenney that her
name is Gwen Stacy and so what we do is
we jump to the reality of spider-gwen
and we picked up with her and the Mary
James now if those are guys who don't
know the Mary James is a band that Gwen
Stacy is part of and that's one of the
reasons why fans liked her character so
much because it was so different it was
it was a wholly new different creation
that was wild that had huge changes from
the main Marvel timeline she was her own
character she had her own group she had
her own friends it was a huge change up
for example Reed Richards is a young kid
instead of being an older experienced
man and so these things are made for a
really cool situation when I when it
came to her character but the fact
remains here that as we would expect
Gwen Stacy if her mind is in the body of
Laura Kenney then it would make sense
that the mind of Moore Kinney is in the
body of Gwen Stacy and that's exactly
what happened here for some reason or
another their minds have swapped now
Gwen Stacy I guess saw Laura Kenney in
the body of Gwen Stacy didn't initially
know this Laura didn't realize what it
was that was going on all she knew was
that she was meeting a guy named George
Stacy she didn't really know who he was
I didn't really understand what was
going on here she was suddenly in a
reality she didn't recognize she was
part of a band that she didn't recognize
it so she was largely beginning to panic
but what happens is the gwen stacy I
guess the Gwen verse version of Reed
Richards appears and says hey we need to
go have a conversation we need to like I
need to inform you of a few things that
are going on now Reed Richards of the
the Gwen Stacy universe was not the one
behind this but he's still extremely
intelligent and so because of this he
was able to easily deduce what it was
was going on and because of this we
basically pick up with him telling Laura
Kinney
in the body of Gwen Stacy look you've
only got about three hours before this
is irreparable before those three hours
expires you need to go to the dimension
where your mind was swapped you need to
find the person that took your mind and
you need to figure out what's going on
now because of the fact that Reed is
pretty intelligent in terms of what he's
capable of
he points her in a pretty solid
direction and so we basically just end
up picking up with with gwen stacy in
the body of x-23 who's talking to harvey
mcaddy
but almost immediately after the two of
them began talking with one another were
suddenly met with the x-23 counterpart
tears spider-ham and this is really cool
because spider-ham was basically spider
pig it was spider it was a pig with the
powers of spider-man and he has a
following that is wild about him like
there are people who love spider-ham I
could never really get into him too much
but I recognize that there are people
who do did you do dig him out the kicker
here is that this this you know
Wolverhampton as he's felt is not
actually here and instead he is a
construct of the mind of you know when
Stacy in the body of x-23 and this
relief seems to be something that she
just made with a purpose of
understanding her situation it's just a
subconscious way of to keep her from
losing her mind but in the midst of her
talking to Wolverhampton she officially
meets Gwen Stacy err I guess the you
know that the spider-gwen character for
the very first time now this is pretty
big because these two have never met but
it makes sense that they would somewhere
along the line because they're two of
the most popular female characters in
the realm of comic books and so because
of this it makes sense that you know the
two of them would come together along
the line somewhere and they would have a
team-up and I'm really hoping this leads
into something a little bit better
because the truth when it came to the
character of spider-gwen while she was a
huge part of spider-verse you know while
there was a lot of
was a lot of struggle between her and
the main universe Peter Parker because
he recognized she was Quinn Stacey and
he didn't want to see her die even if
she was from a different universe
for the most part following the events
of Secret Wars spider gland doesn't she
seems pretty isolated you know with
regards to what it is that she does how
she has things going on she's just kind
of out there in left field and so to see
her crossover more and more with other
characters from the main Marvel Universe
is also something that's really
intriguing one of the downsides to this
though is that a lot of fans want to see
more expansion on her universe they want
to see more expansion the kind of
characters that we see in her universe
the differences between those characters
and the ones that were used to and this
is really just rooted in the fact that
comic book fans like to see alternate
realities of versions you know regarding
characters that they know they like to
see different takes on different
characters sometimes a good sometimes
their bad but it's just interesting to
read about that's one of the reasons why
alternate reality stories are so popular
because we've seen stories where sentry
kills the Marvel Universe for example
but we see stories where you know Miles
Morales becomes spider-man after the
death of Peter Parker we see all these
different you know scenarios and people
really seem to enjoy it but the fact
remains here that with with spider-gwen
and x-23 they come to the realization
that in order to get their bodies back
they basically have to trace the source
of this change and figure out what in
the heck is going on so what they do is
they basically come to the realization
that someone in a room across from them
shot some kind of array that caused
their minds to switch and so when they
trace it to its source of course they
find out that this person's gone but
because of the fact that x-23 has such
incredible sense of smell because she
had the same that that same ability as
Wolverine she's easily able to pick up
the scent of the person who was in the
room and trace that back to a location
that takes them underground and when
they get there they end up in this room
this sealed facility and they begin
investigating around but they also run
into a few booby traps now when the
person who said these booby traps up
makes their appearance they bear a
striking similarity to wasp
or even to to a character called Hornet
that was way back in the day a guy by
the name of Eddie McDonough I believe
and we actually learned the relationship
between this person and Eddie McDonough
is that they were family now of course
x-23 and gwen stacy is spidered window
know this but was also really
interesting is they're learning about
the powers that the other has which is
really cool for example you know Laura
Kenney being in the body of which stacy
has never had an instance where she's
ever used
before and she doesn't realize the
tensile strength of wedding and so when
she shoots it she doesn't know how to
pull it back she doesn't know how to let
that wedding go and then shoot more and
it's really just fun you know to see
that that situation is fun to see a
character that suddenly takes on the
powers of a member of the spider family
but doesn't know how to use them not
only that because when Stacey is in the
in the body of x-23 she's also
experiencing her claws for the first
time and so while she begins to threaten
while she begins to to basically make
the case she's gonna take out hornet she
has her hands to her face she pops her
claws and she stabs herself in the head
and so this is just funny you know to me
it's interesting to see these things
unfold and so in light of seeing you
know of course x-23 seemingly kill
herself
a hornet just kind of became you know
begin sic and reveals her identity and
what we're told here is that what the
character Hornet her story harkens back
to the death of Eddie McDonough now the
death of Eddie McDonough tied in to the
original enemy of the state event which
makes sense because the upcoming story
arc for x-23 is called enemy of the
state now it looks like they're
completely different events it looks
more like it ties into the aftermath of
x-23 turning against Captain America not
really fighting on the side of Sheol but
more or less going rogue away from the
influence of oh man Logan's shield so on
and so forth but in the original event
enemy of the state from 2005 the what
had happened was the original Wolverine
James Holland had been kidnapped by
Hydra in the hand and he had been
brainwashed and turned into an assassin
designed for the purpose of tracking
down and killing all of the superheroes
basically anyone who opposed the desire
of the hand and Hydra to take over the
world now while he was eventually taken
and he was cured of his brainwashing the
story that I uploaded called Wolverine
kills the model universe is a what-if
story on what would have happened if he
wasn't fixed if they never took him
captive and if they never reversed the
brainwashing he eventually just went on
and killed every single super hero and
super villain in the Marvel Universe
Captain America Elektra daredevil you
know the whole nine yards Incredible
Hulk he killed them all and so again
basically what a Hornet tells us here is
that because she was wildly intelligent
as a child because her brother Eddie
realized how intelligent she was he made
the Kaiser made the decision to begin
tutoring her in developing that and
halogens the issue was that following
the death of Eddie for some reason or
another a hornet was basically placed
inside of stasis and she remained
completely isolated from the world but
then what she tells us is that this
happened after the death of her brother
Eddie and her goal was to basically
operate away from Wolverines ability to
locate her and to try to figure out a
way to destroy him the issue was that
because James Howlett was for all
intents and purposes immortal and
because it hadn't quite occurred to
Hornet the simply encase him in
adamantium the idea was to develop a
weapon that would force him to swap
bodies with somebody else and so when
she finally emerged from her stasis from
her hibernation and she discovered you
know wolf rein was alive and active she
didn't realize it was x-23 and so when
she shot x-23 with this device the
result was that it forced her to swap
minds with when stacy putting us in this
current situation and so what happens
that after all this is explained of
course hornet realizes the mistake that
she made she realizes that you know
wolverine james Hallett is no longer
part of the equation because he's dead
he's in case of adamantium and gone and
so what she does is basically just swap
their bodies back there's a simple
conclusion no muss no fuss and it works
out pretty well but what this seems to
do it's basically set the stage for
allowing you know Marvel to move Hornet
into the future of you know most likely
being a partner or a sidekick or maybe
an on-again off-again character in the
x-23 line of stories but it also sets
the stage for future crossovers between
Spyder Glenn and x-23 now whether we'll
actually see that happen that's a
question I don't have the answer to but
I would imagine that a team-up between
the two would be pretty well received I
mean I thought it was a it was a really
cool story the fact that it's
light-hearted I think works out I really
wouldn't want to see like a dark story
with a crossover between x-23 and spider
Gwen but I think the light-hearted
nature of you know of spider-gwen
stories complemented with the relatively
light-hearted nature of x-23 stories
really works out well for the two of
them when it comes to crossing over and
meeting one another but but again you
know because of the fact that their
bodies are switched back to normal the
story dis basically comes to an end of
course Jonathan the Wolverine is uh
seems to be very happy with the
situation gabbi's also happy with the
situation I definitely want to see some
more stuff with Jonathan the Wolverine
he's pretty awesome but if you guys are
new here the comments explained make
sure you guys hit the sub button and if
you guys enjoy this video drop a like
let me know what you all
and leave a comment down below let me
know would you guys be interested in
seeing more crossovers between x-23 and
spider twin cuz I certainly hope Marvel
would get wind of it and definitely give
us more crossovers in the future but
without being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end now we'll catch you
all later peace